chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett joins us now with more on the
debate last night major good morning
listen the reviews are in for Mike
Bloomberg as you know and they are
universally bad with words like
disastrous pummeled stumble stumbled
you've probably seen the front page of
the New York papers hometown paper yeah
his hometown paper yeah right Tony
Black in blum blum goes the dynamite yet
this morning the Bloomberg campaign says
they're pleased with his performance my
question to you how does this happen
to him last night you knew all the
questions were coming and how does he
recover
well you recover by spending even more
money and Mike Bloomberg has unlimited
financial resources I talked to a lot of
Democrats last night both during the
debate and afterwards the consensus was
Bloomberg was unprepared unfocused and
uninspiring and for an opportunity to
make a solid first impression on this
debate stage the consensus among these
Democrats was Bloomberg blew it but that
doesn't mean he's out of it because he
has inexhaustible resources which means
you can put plenty of advertising on the
air to compensate for this one Democrat
talk I talked to said that might cost
him 80 million dollars to compensate for
what he did last night or more precisely
didn't do so when you have that kind of
money you can remain in the game but for
a momentum builder it was an opportunity
missed for sure yeah he definitely has
that kind of money Elizabeth Warren did
a lot of the attacking against Michael
Bloomberg I think some people may have
been reminded of why she became a
national figure in the first place she
can cross-examine someone until they
melt but she has not been doing too well
in the early States does this
performance last night put her back in a
position to win the nomination it gives
her a fighting chance and that's really
the key word because for a long time the
last few weeks Elizabeth Warren has been
talking about party unity will all that
disappeared last night she was clearly
fighting for her political life
attacking in every single direction the
toughest Barb's were at Mike Bloomberg
but there was also criticism for Amy
Klobuchar Joe Biden and Pete Buddha Jets
even a little bit for Bernie Sanders but
looking at the war on performance it
definitely galvanized her supporters got
her back in this game but it also helped
Sanders because when Warren is attacking
everyone else the path is clearer for
Sanders you got to think about that as
well major do you think Bernie Sanders
solidified his position as the
runner I mean he's been surging in polls
and as you point out you we have an
increasing division among the moderates
in the party is he the clear
front-runner now well he is the
front-runner in national polls and he
has momentum in Nevada we don't know
about South Carolina South Carolina is
the great variable and the Bernie
Sanders big momentum question but he
also took some knocks last night not the
biggest by far but questions about his
transparency about medical records how
he's gonna spend how he's gonna pay
rather for his 50 trillion dollar 10
years spending agenda those nicked him a
little bit but he emerged largely
unscathed and when you're leading with
momentum in the next state Nevada and
nationally that's a good place to be all
right major Garrett thank you very much